so we've got the midterm elections some
interesting races I already mentioned
early voting is happening in Florida
early voting starts Saturday which is
October 27th there is a really
interesting race going on in Florida
Democrat Andrew is it Gilliam or Gilliam
Gilliam you think it's Gilliam Andrew
Gilliam the Democrat running against Ron
DeSantis the Republican for Florida
governor there is absolutely hilarious
debate video where De Santis looks
visibly ill like he had mayonnaise well
past its expiration date and it reminds
me of Chris Christie behind Donald Trump
we're gonna put up this picture after
Chris Christie made all sorts of
criticisms of Donald Trump he ended up
endorsing Trump and standing behind him
as Donald Trump said nonsensical thing
after nonsensical thing and as we
pointed out in our audience can see here
were showing the picture chris Christie
looked visibly ill he looked like
physically sick to his stomach from
being there and having to sort of play
this game and why he ultimately did this
we don't really know but he did and Mitt
Romney did and others did there is video
that I'm going to show you where Ron de
santis looks ill as he is just getting
crushed by Andrew Gilliam in the debate
if you're just listening to what we're
about to play it's harder to tell I
encourage you to check out the video of
it every time you see De Santis on
camera and there's a split-screen or
it's just on the cameras just on him he
looks like he knows he's in trouble he
looks like he had some bad clams a
couple of hours earlier take a look at
this well first what Florida voters need
to know is that when they elect me
governor they don't have a governor who
believes in science which we haven't had
for quite some time in this state I'm
not sure what is so California about
believing that the state of Florida out
a lead in solar energy we're known as
the Sunshine State
at the very least what we can do is be a
global leader here we got a to see other
49 states of what to do and what it
means to have a state that quite frankly
leans into the challenges of the green
economy in bills one and at the same
time bills and economy that lasts I'm
proud that the same week that Donald
Trump pulled out of the Paris Accord I
broke ground in my city on a 100
20 acre solar farm tripling the amount
of solar energy that we produce we're
prepared to lead and we've done so in my
city and will do so for the state
Gilliam is just espousing basic good
ideas presented in a straightforward and
simple way it seems to be resonating
with voters voters and DeSantis just
looks ill and uncomfortable and maybe
it's because he knows he's down 12 in a
new poll that's really really good news
for Floridians maybe it's because he is
just getting he it's like a boxer who's
just disoriented from taking hit after
hit after hit he doesn't know where to
look he doesn't know what to say he just
doesn't know how to even make any impact
during this debate you said bad clams
right I think it's bad clams milk mixed
with bad claims yes it's both yeah you
get this face talk about Florida having
such potential but being ravaged by
Republican politicians and lacks gun
laws they've got real climate change
issues to deal with and DeSantis just
making mistake after mistake he doesn't
even seem to know what his own positions
are he pledged to sign a bill to take
care of people with pre-existing
conditions but he's against Medicare for
all he's worried about the debt but his
four states right I mean just
unintelligible positions that are
totally incoherent and really Florida
has two main issues the economy and
climate change and they're both related
if you're underwater the economy is
going to suffer and there is some very
interesting data about how Boston and
Miami are both coastal cities as many
people will know if they've looked at a
map of the United States but Miami has
sort of a limestone I don't know if it's
called a foundation or landmass land
made of limestone limestone is very
porous and salt water seeps through it
so while in Boston there are already
ideas of building some kind of a wall
system similar to what they have in
Amsterdam planning ahead of course for
the climate change and sea level rise
that it's at this point seems to be all
but a foregone conclusion
Miami can't do that because of the
porous limestone that they have and so
they have engineering issues to deal
with there are going to have economic
if they're not able to solve that
tourism and property taxes our main
sources of income for the state of
Florida and the Santis is in a fantasy
world and the survival of Florida
depends on actually just electing
someone like Andrew Gilliam which
Florida has not had someone like Andrew
Gilliam as governor I don't know if ever
but certainly for a very long time I
think Charlie Crist was the last
democratic governor of Florida currently
they have Rick Scott who's running
against Bill Nelson so that's another
race you have in the Senate right yeah
so actually in Florida October 27th is
the early voting date please vote please
vote folks please vote and if you're not
voting let me know because I will be
extraordinarily upset and will try to
shame you into voting because that's
what needs to happen a lot of exciting
races we will be covering all of them
check out some of my behind the scenes
pictures from politican over the weekend
on instagram at david pakman and also
follow the show on instagram at david
pakman show I am thrilled to tell you
that one of today's sponsors is simple
habit calm slash Pakman where you can go
and get a seven day totally free trial
of an app that I use personally and love
I've talked to you before about the
benefits of meditation just simply
sitting there observing what it is that
your mind wants to do has been a great
thing for me we have so much evidence
growing all the time that this is just a
good thing for people to do and one of
the best tools you'll be able to find
anywhere online for guiding you through
meditation is simple habit it just won
the 2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app a very well deserved
award they have guided meditations by
some of the most respected mindfulness
experts from the east and west you can
choose from a huge selection of
five-minute meditations each designed
specifically for where you are or what
you're doing or the mood that you're in
they have meditations for falling asleep
for when you're waking up for your daily
commute when you've just gotten home
from work there are meditations
specially crafted to help people deal
with anxiety or to
focused before doing something difficult
and simple habit lets you keep track of
your progress by giving you feedback
about how much you're meditating how
many days in a row you've been
meditating it's a really comprehensive
and well put together app go check it
out you can try it free for seven days
at simple habit calm slash Pakman I've
put a link underneath this video